hey
hello everyone uh glad to see everyone
is joining in and you're just in time
well not just in time it starts
in about 12 minutes uh so you are about
just in time uh sorry about that for the
leeches titled arena and the
links uh to join are in the description
below so the first link is the actual
tournament and the second link
is to uh join the agar matres chess team
unleashes
so yeah you can just join that and then
i think you automatically enter this
arena
and um yeah we have a lot of a lot of
players in the team however
for this tournament uh while you can all
play only the top 20
uh will will uh be counted so
like it doesn't matter if there are
teams of 20 players and there could be
teams of like
1 000 players only the players that
scored the 20
uh those who score amongst the top 20
will
be counted for and uh yeah i think it's
going to be fun
i'm just gonna be showcasing your games
and reading the chat so
uh hello everyone uh let me just check
once again
uh yeah it seems to be working
everything uh if if anyone can just
say if if the sound is okay uh but yeah
seems that uh seems that it is working
all right so we have uh we have like 11
minutes
until the tournament starts uh for those
of you who are just joining in the link
is in the description below if you want
to join in
and i will repeat this from time to time
during the
during this um uh well stream but
you know worry not it is for the new
viewers
and i think someone just subscribed to
me on twitch but
uh yeah i i use the same overlay on
twitch and youtube so that's why you've
seen that animation
if you've been weirded out by that
no i'm gonna yeah i'm pretty much i'm
gonna i'm gonna go
through all of them but yeah we we will
mostly be
uh watching the the games of the top 20.
but for the moment that we don't know
who uh who are the top 20 so we're
we can start even at the bottom so it
doesn't really doesn't really make a
difference
was i poor in the beginning of my
youtube career no i i would not say i
was poor
no all right
what's my twitch it's uh pretty sure
it's
chess yeah try again chess or maybe it's
again mata's chess i haven't used it in
a while
uh but yeah if anyone wants to play a
game or two while we're waiting for the
tournament to start feel free to drop a
challenge i see there
there are already some i don't know if
those are new ones or or maybe
from before hey peter leonte welcome
welcome to excellent subscribers man
i'm glad glad to have you on board thank
you claudio thank you for
for the for the wishes all right we have
a we have a casual bullet game so let's
let's uh let's do that one
oh the the the current video resolution
is not optimal
why would it not be optimal all right so
i don't have this okay there it is
there's the sound all right so we're
gonna play a few games we don't have
time for a lot of them
uh let's go here we're probably gonna
have to trip
okay that's nice let's check do this
and now we can just castle and try and
okay that's nice let's stop this bring
the knight
here something like this maybe queen
here
uh looks very dangerous bishop f3 kinda
all right he he he kind of stopped that
i like it
well let's let's do this
nope not interested he wants to
sacrifice here we're gonna ignore
okay queen trade nice capture the rook
all right so this is still a game this
is still a game we're up
we're up the exchange okay now uh we
should
kind of win this but you know you never
know in bullet
all all is possible let's kick away this
knight
okay he doesn't allow it but we will
force him he's
he's better on time so there's always
that uh let's go here
let's check and pick up this pawn let's
go after this pawn
yeah that should pin the knight attack
the knight
all right he he sees everything but i
think we'll be able to
uh to win this one nicely all right push
the pawn
he's gonna try and
bring the knight in will not work all
right
let's capture that check and
pick up this guy is this is this uh no
i'm just i'm just checking if it's still
made but it's not stalemate
all right
oh it's your birthday sam the bam yeah
i'm pretty sure
we can have a game uh you are sb one two
three
all right wow okay there are quite a few
challenges but if
okay but we can't play a five plus hole
come on
uh we have like a few minutes until the
tournament starts uh
five plus so it is a bit is a bit too
much
all right we will see if i'm not going
to be too tired after the tournament we
can play some we can play some games but
again i'm black wow all right but we we
will go again
for the for the scandinavian that's what
we do against the e4
and it's such a nice nice uh
nice idea to go for in bullet all right
we kick away the bishop
and then we continue developing this is
all very nice
and now we can even sacrifice some
material here if he allows it
should be fine i'm guessing he's gonna
capture with the knight and then we can
open some lines no all right we're gonna
do this
this and yeah it should be fine
should be fine yeah i could have done
this and then go for this but
whatever
let's go here this is also winning
material
but i'm not in a rush to win material
all right let's go here
threaten checkmate maybe um yeah i
thought he would
okay now it's going to be a bit
difficult to stop mate
he's gonna have to give up the bishop
maybe
i don't know we'll see
it was a pretty pretty wild
wild game all right let me just check
good game uh good game mr
dark myth 78 all right let me just
check if uh if our
birthday friend uh switched to a lower
time format so we can play one
uh before
before the tournament starts i don't
think so
can you promote to a light square bishop
if one already has a light square bishop
yeah
of course okay yeah everyone's been
asking me about the
the hikaru and eric drama but i i
actually don't
know anything about that i mean i i only
uh uh use twitter uh for you know
uh from social networks and i really did
not
you know even try to figure out what
happened there i know they had some sort
of an argument about something but
that's that's as far as i know about it
uh and i've seen the video i actually
thought the video was kind of fake
i thought it was like like a montage
that mr dodgy made
but obviously not ah you you got
strolled by
you got trolled by the april fool's
thumbnail yeah
sorry about that all right so it starts
in four minutes i guess we can play one
more game oh we
we uh for now we have a grand master on
the team actually gula
gula pop uh from hungary now now a
german grand master i don't know if he
will actually play but he did join the
team
so uh could be could be a lot of very
good points for us
yeah i don't know i thought it was funny
i thought it was funny
i i've seen a lot of people did not
enjoy my
april's fool's day a prank but most of
you most of you
enjoyed it
blunderking you have been shout out
aye it's jula are are you sure it's jula
okay i i do not know that i i was pretty
certain it's giula
all right jukarich zukarich analysis uh
i think we have time for one more bullet
before before the start
yeah and i i really i really thought
that people would figure out it's uh
it's a prank before
uh you know like before the the 10th
second
even even uh finishes uh i guess not
you know but okay most of you most of
you did figure out it was a joke
all right let's uh shift this knight
here i guess
i sacrificed the pawn for no no good
reason i'm gonna sacrifice a queen here
uh just because i sacrificed the pawn
for no reason and
maybe maybe it'll be good maybe not
we'll see
if he captures i'm gonna go here no he
won't okay
let's go here let's go here
try and trade okay i will pick up the
free pawn
it's not free i know but what are you
gonna do
all right this knight if it moves okay
that's a bit of a problem but not
not that big of a problem okay of course
he's not gonna allow that
let's try this all right we're we're
playing
qui what is that was that a mouse slip i
did not
see uh wow i took my
hair away from from that for for a
second and already
something like this happens wow all
right so i guess we we need to
get access to this square somehow
if we can do that we'll be fine all
right of course he's gonna do that
all right he's going after us let's
let's not allow that
how do we how do we stop that not a lot
of good ways
yeah not a lot of good ways yeah okay
i'm gonna blunder something yeah okay we
start by wandering the bishop of course
okay we can't really do this
have to avoid as many of them as
possible
okay that's that's a bit of a okay now
now he got me okay good job good job you
got me
all right that was a that was a nice one
jukarich analysis
that was uh that was a wild one uh i
know it wasn't
the the greatest of moves but i already
gave a mouse
uh not a mouse upon for nothing so
i thought why not why not try with the
queen as well
all right so are we starting yeah we're
starting in 52 seconds
so we're gonna uh we're gonna shift to
the tournament now
uh i'm gonna be showcasing the game so
let's see probably
going to be really wild straight from
the start
and uh it's a two-hour tournament so it
doesn't matter if you just joined the
links are in the description below
and so you can join our team i i think
for now we have some 18 000 people there
uh but like i said only the top 20 who
earned the most points will be
accounted for uh so you know we don't
know how how many points will uh
someone make so let's uh
let's try and grab some points how do
you arrow unleashes
i think you just you know make arrows
like
with the right mouse mouse click
all right uh so the team's the the game
started all right we're gonna start with
our only grand master and
team so far facing uh against grand
master sergey zigako who is a bullet
expert but
this is uh this is blitz so let's see
let's see how they do it
play the bomb cloud yeah uh i don't i
don't know
we probably will be seeing some bond
cloud uh not too much
i i i think yeah just right click and
drag like this i mean
you right click and you draw arrows like
you can draw arrows you can draw circles
i don't know if you can yeah you can
even do uh different color circles
so you know there's a lot you can do
so okay let's see let's see what's
happening here
a lot of action uh black has a really
cramped position but i i guess that's
what he was going for he's gonna play on
the queen side now a little bit
i or right mouse button is broken yeah
that's
gonna make it a bit difficult for you to
do to do arrows
did i stop streaming on twitch i didn't
stop streaming on twitch i just
stopped for the moment i will return to
it at some point
uh we're in the process of moving right
now so i'm not setting up
any sort of a streaming environment here
but as soon as we move
uh i'm gonna set up a proper streaming
environment and uh probably gonna stream
uh on a daily basis uh
maybe not like every day but you know if
i you know
if i manage it then uh then definitely
alex from romania greetings man
hey mitch you were depressed
for the entire day because magnus was
quitting quitting chess
i'm sorry about that
all right
will my card still be in the background
yes corey campbell
uh the couch is coming with me i would
not part with it so easily
it's uh you know it's a great couch
jimmy lebron i'm um uh
one 191 centimeters
joined wesley saw on the american chess
team yeah
i mean in my dreams
hey marcus from estonia thanks thanks
for the
congratulations man thanks a lot
do i prefer the bar or the library a one
one does not work without the other
spending too much time in a bar is bad
spending too much time in the library
also bad you have to you know
50 50 at least
yeah we will be doing kasparov saga at
some point but
not not just yet uh although he's
retired he's still an active player he
he comes out of retirement every year to
play some chess
all right so how are we doing here black
still
i don't know either black's pushing or
he's being pushed
but i think uh well time wise time wise
we're okay
all right
it's gonna be gonna be pretty crazy
yeah carp of saga also also at some
point but he's still also pretty active
okay not
not that active but
who am i rooting for in the candidates
uh
i really don't have a preference i mean
uh whether
whether uh as nepo and uh and maxim are
leading the tournament
if either of them win i mean that's
going to be a great world church
championship match
all right so i i guess uh it will all
come down to to a bullet as
all blitz games do
the reti opening i've i've heard it's a
it's a magnificent opening
all right so i think white is just
trying to get black to waste
time so that that does not go in our
favor
as i know jigalco is extremely fast
so we'll see we'll see how far that
that pawn can go
all right
or this will be this will be crazy this
will be crazy
19 seconds all right can
can he make some sort of a breakthrough
here he's
yeah he was threatening to win the queen
by moving the knight with check
all right 34 seconds against
13 wow yeah he had to do that
he had to do that and now the knight has
to go here
attack the rook he's gonna have to give
up the rook and then uh he'll probably
win on time
but he does have a lot of pawns he does
have a lot of pawns we'll see if it's
possible
okay he he gets the queen out right away
to
to win some seconds wow
all right that pawn is gonna fall but
not enough time yeah all right that was
that was a wild one
that was a really wild one great game by
both of them congratulations to jigalco
uh on winning this one uh all right
let's see who do we have someone from
the from the lower parts of our table
all right i am six has just started
playing so let's check out this one
will this stay on youtube yeah it will
stay on youtube yeah
uh i think all all of my all my streams
stay on youtube
pretty sure when will i start using my
new studio well we're in the process of
moving for the past uh
five months now or no four months so it
should be
should be any day now
surak yeah it would be yeah okay
uh playing playing chess against any of
the old legends would be
would be uh pretty amazing meeting
morphy
i don't know i don't think i would even
want to play morphe i would just like to
you know have a have a nice conversation
with morphy
ah what is the status of chess manga
well i've heard that
the second chapter has just been
finished and we should be releasing it
in in a few days so uh you know hope
you're ready for that it's gonna be
much much denser than chapter one and uh
uh well i'm i'm pretty sure you're gonna
enjoy it if you if you enjoyed the idea
behind the the age of kaiser and
uh you know if you enjoy chapter one
then chapter two you will you will
really enjoy
firuja is a gambler why is why is he a
gambler
when will i become a father uh should be
in some two three months
uh depending on you know how how it all
plays out
you know my real name darren i i think
everyone knows
it's public knowledge
no ronald i i don't know i do not watch
attack on titan i heard it's really
great
like i've read like season one is great
season two and three are okay because
you know different teams worked on
season one then on season two and three
and like uh i don't know i will watch it
at some point just haven't
gotten around to it yet all right mate
being threatened can we deliver mate
here
nope so what now
nah going to be great for us white is
white is going to struggle a lot here
have i ever play uh strategon no no i
haven't
hey hello daniel came by there you go
man
all right nater you're number 27 on the
team we're gonna we're gonna check it
out
is there a chess anime well we are we
are
you know in the process of getting there
yoyo's bizarre adventure yeah and
netflix has been offering me to watch
that for
for quite some time now i've been
avoiding it because the thumbnails are
really
uh but you say it's good for chess
players okay i might i might
i i might check it out i've been looking
for my next
next one to dive into
did i ever have a fever from thinking
too much in chess
no i don't think me maybe a slight no
not headache but maybe a slight you know
uh
blood rush to the to the to the forehead
all right i don't think we are doing
well here
uh it's two pieces for for the rook also
we're down on time
so we'll see
yes marcus mueller those are games uh of
subscribers
for those of you who are just joining in
uh we are participating in a tournament
where
10 uh 10 teams face off against each
other uh we are
one team and it doesn't matter if there
are 20 000 of us
in the team only the games of those who
earned the most points the the top 20 of
those who earn the most points
uh will be counted for in the end so
even teams that only have
20 members can uh you know participate
properly
against those who have many more members
in their team
thereon i don't have to put you on the
team everyone is on the team
there there are links to this in the
description below uh second link is for
you to join our team
and the first is to this tournament
which you can immediately join
there's no like uh strict beginning of
the tournament
where you have to be is the guinness the
perfect
drink for chess players uh i i don't
think so
yeah i'm not not the not a big guinness
fan
do i ever read message on instagram very
very rarely like maybe maybe on the
toilet or something like that but
uh you know
all right uh we lost this one maybe uh
better better luck in the next one so
how are we doing
uh for the moment uh okay we're actually
doing great we're actually third
so far uh all right so let's see
who do we have someone someone from the
back
pawn omega not playing not playing not
playing not playing
uh this is already over hey filipino is
playing let's check out filipinos game
he's on uh currently on a
on a on the defensive he's
up he's up a night but we'll see if it
works out
hey learning the ropes thank you for the
contribution thanks a lot
keep up the great analyses uh well
they are frequent and i do enjoy them i
would not call them great but
thank you
do i smoke cigarettes no i've smoked a
lot uh but i've
i've gave up smoking some four years ago
all right i think i think he he has this
it's not gonna be all right now queen
check picks up the rook there i don't
think there are some tricks here
or there there could be but i don't
think there are
ah yeah i don't know when when will my
next podcast be i don't think i will be
doing the
the same podcasts uh with the
uh with the same setup that i've been
doing so far as
like i said uh we're moving so it's
probably going to be in the new setup
and it's probably going to be a bit more
casual uh i don't know
uh we'll see hopefully hopefully er
pretty soon
do i know chronology and filipino
personally yes of course
once my brother brother-in-law wants my
nephew
[Laughter]
all right phillip is
up a rook so there's really no no more
worries here will white try to
to be devious nope white resigns good
game filipino
all right let's see who do we have let's
see
if there's a nice game in progress okay
here's a nice uh
quality game i believe losing tactics
against mercap 2021
maddie if i know so much about chess why
am i not above 2000 i am above 2 000 not
a lot i'm like
in class coming like 21 something uh but
that's like saying if you know a
football commentator
is uh all that great why doesn't he play
for the team why does it why does he
just commentate the games
that it doesn't really relate
yeah the podcast with cosmology dude was
nice chris
yeah i really enjoyed that one i really
hoping to
do more of them and i probably will and
uh i'm
i'm probably gonna start uh inviting
more people from all sorts of areas
and even something that i have planned
for for my subscribers if any of you are
doing anything interesting in any field
uh you will be welcome to join me uh for
an event like this you know
we're gonna have a tournament and have a
nice discussion about whatever you guys
are doing
uh be it gardening or you know astralis
astronomy or you know
anime or whatever it's just the perfect
game
i don't know if chess is the perfect
game but there is
no game that comes as close to
perfection i would say
of course that's completely you know my
opinion
do i watch the games from croatian
junior league no not really but
uh if a great game happens uh then
people
you know uh send it to me
and uh well
or rather if a great game happens
anywhere
uh people tend to send me games and uh
so i don't miss any
i'm from croatia for those of you who do
not know
chevebor welcome to excellent
subscribers man glad to have you on the
team
it's the it's the most elite team of all
teams uh
you join without getting any perks so
it's you know
that can only be found on this channel
no nowhere nowhere in the world
do you have that
yeah favorite anime as usual uh always
always dragon ball
big dragon ball fan here
i don't i don't have a take on the chess
drama as
like i said i'm not familiar with what
happened at all and
uh not okay can't really say that that
i'm interested
have to do too much work to you know be
dealing with that
schweppe finally you can call now you
were always an excellent subscriber now
now you just have a badge
hey bennett bennett barnes welcome to
excellent subscribers man
the the most elite of of uh societies
do i know mato yelich not personally but
of course i know of him
uh when i first you know visited youtube
insert
chess of course there was mato yelich
the the legend
how do i think croatia will fare in the
euros i
i imagine you are referring to football
uh
you i don't know i always think that
they're gonna do great and then you know
they either do or don't
all right okay a very nice
very nice end game here do you guys know
if this is a win or a draw
you should know if this is a win or a
draw because
uh this can happen and then if you don't
know
it's going to be a problem
yeah there there are pawns that are
winning there are pawns there that are
drawn
these pawns are drawn and these pawns
are are winning
yeah uh but you know here here it kind
of
uh didn't work out uh but okay
a draw is also very nice all right
so who do we have next we're gonna check
out uh we have time the
the tournament lasts for two hours so
it's not a problem
uh we we can check out many games all
right so i'd like to see one that starts
from the beginning like this one okay
it's not the beginning but everything is
pretty much still on the board
and i like this light square bishop yeah
slight square bishop is looking really
really really great
do i know riders of the storm by doors
of course i do
i i'm kind of from from that era
yeah i was in this position that it was
a draw
no i'm not playing i'm showcasing games
uh by subscribers this is a
this is a team event and uh team agar
is facing against nine other teams and
we are trying to do to do our best
do i play chess in my chess club yeah
but we don't have anything
right now but no no one has anything
right now anywhere in the world
what kind chess takes away stress
yeah it's like uh
and an old old fox saying
what's my favorite opening in chess i'm
pretty sure
everyone in the chat can tell you that
no ll i am not an international master
what's marion asks what's my cat's name
i do not have a cat it's
it's my neighbor's cat the the cat only
comes to visit
all right so uh a nice win nice win for
us
rude j8 uh thank you for winning points
for our team how are we doing still in
third place
uh we're okay we're a little bit in
front of chess network but it's still
you know
only a few points and jigarjo sergey and
friends are really really crushing at
369 points very nice
very nice all right barbarian attacker
let's see if uh
yeah yeah the chat knows the chat knows
uh mom kisser and hugger
okay uh okay uh this one's just starting
out so let's check out this one
no i i i really enjoy let zeppelin but i
do not
listen to them like actively
recommendation for practicing endgame
any any book we'll do any book will do
rate hikaru's apology i can't really
rate it i i i've seen it on two on on on
reddit i think but i've i haven't been
in the you know uh in the process when
everything was happening so i can't
really
can't really say
if if he wrote himself uh you know it's
uh it's
i i guess it's fine
do i play othello no i've i've heard of
it
uh you know i've been offered to play it
once or twice
uh while while visiting friends but i've
never played it
good morning man
you are stuck at 1500 rating what to do
to improve you have to you have to study
the end game
that's that's the only way to improve
what's 992 oh that's uh that's a great
mystery
all right so we we got the rook very
nice and we want to grab it with
check not just grab it that's it a nice
queen to h4 checkmate the bishop covers
this square very very
very nicely done all right returning to
uh picking the players all right
zookarich let's see how duke rich is
doing
and then we're gonna shift into the the
top 20 for a little bit
i got rid of my mailing address on the
about page no i don't think i have
or if i have i i did it by accident so
i'm gonna check
but it's the exact same email address i
was just trying to delete
the other one because people were you
know sending me stuff regarding to
everything to the manga address and i
don't know why
have i thought about any names for the
baby yeah we we have uh
quite a few that's that's kind of the
problem not the shortage of names but
you know just the
that there are too many how many gm's in
jigalco's team
i have no idea we're gonna check
i don't know who will win jake paul or
ben
askren um i imagine it's some sort of a
boxing thing
i know the the paul dudes are are into
that
hey hello richard
hope you're you're enjoying chess every
day
what happens if one team is full of
engine users well i
imagine they win there's there's no way
way to prevent this
all right c4 let's see how we how we
deal with this
we have to watch out for stuff but this
is nicely protected
and is there some other other fun stuff
yeah rook comes into play hmm very
interesting
very interesting
uh if it's a boy no it's not a boy it's
it's actually a girl
yeah i've posted this uh uh uh
okay i don't expect you you guys to to
know about that but yeah
i think i did post it on uh on my
youtube feed yeah
rook capture screen characters all right
all right so we're doing better on time
our position is better i would say
um it's gonna be pretty pretty wild this
is a nice pawn so we'll see
we'll see what happens can he
hang on to it doesn't seem like it all
right so i i think we we got this
how do i deal with the fame oh there
there's really not all that all that
much to deal with
no no one really bothers you here it's a
very very very small town
and not a lot of people care about chess
all that much you know
maybe maybe if i played fortnight maybe
then
i i wouldn't say i'm good at pronouncing
names
uh actually i actually figure i'm quite
terrible at it
especially those french names i really
butchered them
yeah no no all right king g2 let's see
all right so it's uh it's a draw but uh
zukarich has more than twice the time so
i guess maybe he could push
for a win here maybe maybe a bit too
early for a rook trade because
i don't know it okay he's gonna push for
it he's gonna push for it
i would have waited a bit a few more
seconds before
committing to a pawn push but we'll see
if he can win on time that's going to be
great
can i ask danny ranch why there isn't a
carlson oracle spar of bot unchess.com i
i don't think danny has anything to do
with that or or he
decides uh you know those kind of things
i think they have people who
who take care of that all right one more
second oh no now it's just
flag fest all right congratulations very
nice flag fest
uh jukarich takes the win in this one
okay now we can shift a little bit
to the top ones afghan physicist
handler uh joseph how is this all right
here's a very nice attacking game
let's just uh run through it real
quickly okay a nice scandinavian
black gave a pawn and white gave the
pawn back
and now we are at this position
here all right so
i don't think black will be all that all
that happy but
uh you never know he's down a piece but
he
he is trying he's trying very hard
can i analyze kovacic versus fischer i'm
pretty sure i covered that
maybe even twice i've covered it once
not sure about twice
i should name my daughter captura
yeah it's uh it's not bad actually
morphe versus carlson who would win or
depends
how much food do i put on the table
just enough you know
like like goldilocks just right
am i planning on also having a sun i i
don't think it works like that
can i cover stockfish versus leela uh
was there a well of course if there was
some sort of a
really really wild game of course i
would appreciate it if you guys
sent me a an email with with a link to
the game
do i work out yeah i've started to
after my surgery i've been going
actively for like a month
now uh but yeah i am i'm
easing into it and i'm enjoying it a lot
more after my surgery uh
since you know nothing really uh hurts
while i while i exercise
why is there a chocobo on my videos uh
well that's uh that's a secret
but i also really like chocobos they're
the they're the greatest
am i pulling up a sock well well i'm
sorry about that
yes sometimes sometimes both of them
thank you yeah i mean i would i would
really love to visit georgia
uh but uh you know don't know if uh
visiting will be will be a thing
all right so luckily we have this oh
wow nice if this bishop would was here
we lose to a nice modern mate
wow this was this was really crazy
smells
smells from algeria really went wild in
this one but
we we were able to to take the win all
right nicely done
uh no i have uh i have not heard from
uh agatha matorino but i've uh
i'm pretty sure i've seen him play
hearthstone uh with his with his account
so i think
i think everything is fine but i will i
will check again
just to be perfectly safe namaste
justin john namaste alright so where did
we
uh where did we leave it all right this
is a tactician fast uh going for
some sort of let me just quickly go
through the game to see what happened so
oh
nice it was a cillian with the immediate
b4
uh i think it's the mengarini variation
or something like that
all right so here some pawn pushing some
pushing pushing
oh and here we had a nice sacrifice
queen d3 check we win back the night not
really sacrifice but a nice
nice capture captures captures check
and castles and this is where we left it
off
all right so doing doing really nicely
and playing against a very strong player
against the doctor x stranger
rated 25 75 very nice
very nice indeed
yeah i know it's the wing gambit all of
those b4 are the wing gambit but i
i thought this one was uh particularly
called the mangarini
will i attend chess tournaments to do
interviews with players
i i kind of don't see that happening as
there are there are too many people
doing that
and they do it very well so i don't i
don't think i would contribute
uh all that much in that in that
direction kami tabiani
also thanks for the contribution man
a3 thank you thank you for that
but didn't he play a3 i'm pretty sure he
did play a3
b4 and then the immediate a3 but okay
i i could be wrong
kasparov versus d blue i've covered
kasparov versus deep blue
uh i think already yeah we've covered
the
more the more important games i've never
covered the
the entire match uh like completely to
sort of
make a movie like uh about it but
uh yeah we probably will we'll do it
hey david chop thank you for the for the
heads up man
thanks for the contribution man i i'm i
seem to have missed it
but nothing misses our moderator david
david chop is always uh always present
how are how are you always present david
job that's really really impressive
like you're always present
hey dennis from cologne thank you thanks
for the confusion man
yeah i mean i'm very glad that so many
of you are uh
suggesting games via email now
queen here queen here and of course now
rook here and he resigns because there's
no defense
next move he's gonna play rook to h4 and
that's it
we can never move anywhere because this
will be checkmate and a very very
very nice game indeed by tactician uh
tactician finest
this is such a good game that we're
gonna check out uh another one of his
games with the black pieces
to see if he's maybe on some sort of a
crazy run
uh why why why is there no leela versus
alpha zero uh there's no
there is no really no point like if if
uh
alpha zero was brought back online alpha
alpha would become as strong as alpha
needs to be like al alpha 0 is like
superman he's as strong as he needs to
be
and it would be pretty much pointless
for for for off zero to play against
anyone or anything
greetings to elber gala gallarga
who is who is enjoying
the the the games
once you started learning strategy you
started playing worse
that's that's how it goes you have to
learn strategy then you start losing
games
and then after you know a very long time
you become unbeatable
that's how chess works
kauchik doing well man doing well
all right let's see can tactician fest
pull off another another one like like
like the previous one where he just
destroyed him
gph why why are you so bad at chess
so that's a question we we all ask
ourselves at some point
there's no good answer
or you know maybe we just don't like the
answer
all right so he's pushing he's really
pushing it
this is really crazy like the threat is
rook
capture is followed by a nice checkmate
and yeah of course now if rook captures
then queen captures bishop
yeah now he has to do it or no it's
he can't do anything yeah this is just
game wow
[Laughter]
wow okay that's resigns but no okay he
he will make make some room for his king
it will not make much of a difference
but wow this was a nice one we're gonna
have to see this one again in slow
motion
all right and the nice uh discovered uh
plus also also
uncovered check so we're gonna check out
this one
like a very nice attack from here like
first knight g3
attacking the queen white accepts it and
then we're
threatening uh this of course after rook
or bishop captures here
because the knight cannot recapture it's
pinned and then
there's just nothing to be done here he
attacked the bishop thinking
you you could do that but just bishop
captures and this is really amazing mate
is being threatened
now he needs some room for for the king
on f1 but it doesn't really matter
check check and now wow beautifully
beautifully done this is uh amazing
stuff
all right let's see uh adam adam not
playing fearless finlay not playing
uh all right this one looks like
like a nice one angle versus
probably pravyarvak let's see if he can
win this one
frost you would love to see games of
kramnik versus anand
the uh from from 2008.
uh i don't think i've ever covered
either even a single game from there
uh but i don't think uh yeah i think
that match
is uh kind of not considered to be the
most exciting one probably that's why
why we we haven't even gotten around to
it but you know at some point i mean
there there's so much
to cover i i i have no idea when i will
be able to do it
thomas love kosovo it's i'm only
commenting not really even commenting
we are just playing against nine other
teams and i'm just reading the chat
that's basically how this works
the melo uh thank you for the
contribution man
it was at this point yeah
all right so this is covered the queen
is pretty much stuck here
and now if we can just trap it somehow
yeah if we prevent this yeah i thought
he maybe
go something like rook here and then the
queen is trapped forever
but he has he has other plans i believe
in his plan
more than i do in my plan definitely
lou beliwa thanks for the contribution
man love from the philippines
i will i will try to keep up the good
work thank you very much
robert j fisher equals goat yeah
people do say that
uh urban urbani from vienna no i don't i
mean of course i will be commenting on
the world championship
uh that i mean i i i don't see a
universe where i miss that
uh i will not be doing it live as there
are so many uh
great live coverages that i myself enjoy
uh not just the official one but also
the other ones but
the official by judith polgar uh is i
mean
i will will be uh incredible as as it
always is
uh but uh i will definitely cover the
games afterwards uh once
you know the official uh the official
broadcast finishes
so when will we hear a song of the
infamous group gadovi
uh maybe maybe on the next big milestone
maybe i don't know
it's not that uh it's not that you know
something people would enjoy
i would say
uh but no seriously it's uh you know
maybe an acquired taste
but i i will consider it definitely yeah
all right how are we doing here we are
much better on time and we have more
pawns
that's uh i mean that's all uh one one
could ask for
white missed it oh okay but you know
both are very low on time it's it's
kind of normal that they'll be missing
stuff
why are leaving your sofa behind
what do you mean why i'm leaving
i don't i don't i don't know
please play the morphe bot on chess.com
is it a is it a good bot i don't know
i'd be i'd be
i'd be very sad if it didn't crush me in
some sort of an immortal game but i will
try playing it i will i will play it uh
in in the hardest toughest level and see
if
i if i manage to you know i'm going to
try to lose
in the greatest possible way all right
so this is not completely winning and he
resigns
like every game we show we win that's
pretty awesome
and we're kind of close to the second
place
so we're doing pretty great now on third
place let's see how our
only grand master on the team is doing
again uh with with the black pieces uh
we'll see we'll see how it goes
frost thanks for the contribution one
once again
and also john papora thanks for the
contribution
i should be one of the live commentators
for the next bog
champs yeah i i could see myself doing
that yeah
might not be might not be all that's
terrible
where is the link the link is as usual
in the description below
as a fellow creation in which town do i
live i live in kriegertse
ah you won against my bot in the danish
gambit congratulations
who is my favorite player from
azerbaijan
i i would have to say kasparov i would
have to say kasparov
tournament of stars 1979
i am not familiar with this tournament
at least not under
uh that name but i will make a memo of
it uh to check it out later
tournament of stars
all right we'll be checking that out
mika shran thanks a lot thanks a lot
11 run
how good is the towel variation of the
karo khan it's the only good variation
of the karo khan if you if you
if you're talking about the the h4 pawn
push
on the highest level of course it's uh
it doesn't really bring all that much
and our leader lost no
no it was a it was a fork
he started pushing the pawn and then
went for a queen trade
which would ensure a win because well
but then just oh man
yeah but that's time he was very low on
time
what are you gonna do adam from turkey
nope
let's see how how fearless finlay
is going
when is the continuation of the barn
saga oh we've uh
we have to we we'll do a very short barn
saga
don't worry about it but maybe not like
a video
after video after video make maybe like
maybe like a short movie of mr barnes
uh where we will talk about his greatest
achievements you know and and
games
next suggestion mail is incoming
tomorrow looking forward to it
looking forward to it
now for those of you asking i really
don't have any opinion on the chess
drama
between eric and and hikaru as i know
nothing about it and i didn't even try
to to find out
what was happening like i said i only
used twitter pretty much of
for from social networks and
there really wasn't all that much on
twitter about it and
i'm not on twitch so
right let's see the queen is under
attack
we might even now we can't no i thought
i thought maybe we can give it up but
yeah that's pretty nice actually
huh
can i recommend the live commentator for
the world championship
on youtube for the for the world
championship on youtube like for
for a world chess championship
why am i not on twitch well uh i guess
twitch does have some
uh advantages if you're streaming but
i'm not streaming all that much
and uh i don't know i i don't
i i still don't um
uh like i mean i i do like twitch i just
uh for like regular streamers like
myself uh
uh youtube youtube serves just fine
i still don't don't really have a a
reason to
to move and fearless finlay loses okay
that's the second game i've chosen
that we've lost we have to go to our
always winning tactician finest and he's
again
playing some sort of a crazy game so who
knows
what will happen here who do i think
will win the candidates
uh i don't know like my guess is as good
as yours
uh both nipple and and maxime have very
good chances but
you know one slip and it could be could
be anyone could be geary could be fabi
i i still haven't uh you know uh decided
whether ding
is really out of the competition because
you know two wins and he he's back in
here milan i redid the game between tal
and sweten
uh quite a few times already i think i
also did it for the
uh maybe one two hundred thousand
subscribers or something like that
uh i'm pretty sure i did it
alright so tactician finest
uh really pushing this one he's up upon
and he has a very active position better
on time we'll see
and uh up the exchange of course but uh
uh not gonna be easy for black
should you continue playing in the team
even though it's already 4 a.m in your
area
i i see no reason why not if you don't
have like
work in work at six a.m in the morning
then definitely
one one suggestion per day
one suggestion per day that's that's too
many
i i'm only one person
no this is not the good stuff this is
this is the
uh this is the the the great stuff
so kind of different from the good stuff
but uh
uh you know the games here are really
really really wild
who will be the next champ after magnus
again your your guess is as good as mine
and what do we have here a draw wow
urbani uh what does up the exchange mean
oh he's up the exchange so
if you give up for example a knight uh
for a rook
or rather if you if you give up a rook
for a night uh rook is worth more
so your opponent will obviously be up
the exchange
uh so that's kind of called the exchange
when you give up the rook for a bishop
or a knight
so never never never thought about that
yeah but uh
that is of the exchange all right so
there was a draw at least we've uh you
know stopped
the losing streak but it was a really
really wild one
all right let's see uh do we have anyone
magic lord all right
this no magic this one's a
uh pretty wild who who
who can tell what's happening here wow
yeah obviously gmxqc
how can i do all my videos without
cutting what what good would cutting
do i mean you're not gonna
wha what good would would cutting do
richard retti versus stratacore 1910 i'm
pretty sure we we covered that game many
times under many different
uh characters playing them even even as
the simpsons played it
will i cover fischer's second match uh
against posky yes in in saint stefan yes
we will cover that
love from summer's channel give my give
my best to some i guys
rui lopez saga yeah
i will do a rue lopez saga i've actually
read a book
a a nice short book about chess history
and there was quite a lot about about
rue lopez there
and uh yeah not not maybe
but yeah for like a 20 minute video
where you know you will
introduce people to to real lopezy i'm
definitely
you know definitely a plan
jh thanks a lot man all right so
we're doing how are we doing here uh
yeah i think i think everything is you
know going
going our way not there aren't any
threats we can just
push those pawns yeah it's a pretty
pretty good one
can i show more morozevich games yeah i
could i mean
uh just suggest the game
uh he he played so many of them that uh
i mean we would have a
hard time picking you know picking out
for from the great ones
yeah rue lopez was a badass that that is
true
do i know where is montenegro well i am
from croatia so
yeah at some point i i'm i i i will do
uh uh you know complete sagas on those
really really old players
like uh like philidor
how can you become a subscriber whoa
that's uh that's a tough one
uh you you just subscribe it's it's free
you are not able to put up a username in
leeches how do you do it
not not really sure i understand that
but
well i don't think that's even a
question was lasker one of the
the greatest players ever i mean that's
that's pretty certain
hey mark mark good uh give my best to to
to both of your sons
all right so we lose this one
unfortunately
but what are you gonna do i don't know
how it happened
uh i guess i guess our magic
tried to play on an opponent's time but
it kind of backfired and
that's it all right how will
let's see let's see a win by our our
grand master leader
yeah i've had that suggestion for
uh for quite a few times now
i don't have plans on covering stockfish
versus leela but
if there's an interesting game by all
means do do suggest it
i i still haven't decided anything on
the front of of
uh of uh rashid nishmedinov in the
honorary grand master title
i don't know the the honorary grand
master title afide can say that
uh it's the same as as a grandmaster
title but
uh i don't know i i i don't think people
agree with that and doesn't really
matter what fide says
what is this website this is this is
leeches.org
why do i not have terrible music in the
background of my videos
i i don't know i i do have it in one of
my videos it's actually a great game
uh sam shanklin versus vasily van chuk
uh
check it out it's from the capablanca
memorial uh there's some terrible music
in the background so if you if you
haven't seen that video you know you can
check that out
no i did not start calling tal misha
because of that
i just first you know it took me a while
to really figure out
the whether whether uh it's going to be
tall or it's going to be thai
like more of a
not not an english pronunciation of the
name but
in the end i i decided to stick with tal
as uh he he was a latvian and you know
hey brian hey thanks thanks for the
contribution man i i do try i do try
ah she's been in one of the streams yeah
if you're talking about the t-shirt yeah
no magnus magnus did not really retire
how many of my subscribers would i say
are from venezuela
uh in percentage like in numbers i don't
know but like in percentage maybe
yeah it's basically the same thing okay
but i i don't know
i will check maybe like uh maybe like
0.4 percent
do i think sultan khan deserves a an
honorary gm title
uh i guess everyone deserves it uh you
know
just asking that question makes you
think that he deserves it
uh but yeah sultan khan is a legend
and i think daniel king just wrote uh
maybe not just right now he wrote a nice
book about him
i haven't read it but uh i imagine it's
it's great why wouldn't it be
so i i guess if you're interested a bit
more in sultan khan
you can check that out uh
all right excellent victory uh by our
uh by our leader grandmaster hila pop
uh so let's see how we are doing we are
still in third place
uh trailing by uh well quite a few
points actually some 45 points
uh and uh and friends are of course
far far ahead but it's still early in
the tournament still an hour to go so we
we might be able to do it
uh i don't follow any other sports other
than chess
sometimes i will watch a football game
if like the
if there's like a world championship or
something like that but other than that
not not really like okay if
i mean and there's really i enjoyed
going somewhere with people to watch it
but now that you know you don't go
anywhere with people
like i'm not going to watch watch it by
myself
what do i think of georgia balashevich
dying well what
what would i what is there to think
about that
i i'm not really sure
yes paul morphy well said well said
all right so
how do we continue this a nice check is
in order
but where a nice pawn push that's
that's the stuff okay this is nicely
preventing us from getting checkmated
but i still it's it's not going to be
easy
all right now we're up material
very nice yeah i thought he would go for
that
and now it's completely winning very
nice wow
this was very nicely done
when is the next episode of the morphe
saga when when would you like it to be
who is the guy in the picture of every
video
that's uh that's a great mystery
uh which which doll's favor uh famous
game against larson
i don't know
no i have not been to saint louis
pre-coveted i've been invited many times
but
unfortunately never visited so far
uh yeah uh my my 60 memorable games
is uh is a fine collection of of fishers
games
yeah uh life and games of of mikhail tal
that's a that's a must
must-have
can i play hoodie guy yeah i i don't
know if
if anything chess.com should really
implement hoodie guy
as you know a celebrity i mean who who's
who's more famous than mr hoodie guy
they should really implement him
all right so that was uh that was a nice
one uh
let's see cookie versus cookie versus
cookie no it's cookie versus ray trout
ray trout all right cookie is really
pushing here
let's see let's see how this this plays
out
best karpov book i don't know i really
don't know
i don't think i know i don't think i've
ever seen a carpool book
nader dictator you are 29 on the team
all right we're checking out nader the
theater after this one
habibi smile thank you for the
contribution man
have i seen towel versus koblenz 1961.
yeah i'm pretty sure i have
thank you vortex academia
thanks for the contribution
guys uh just use hashtag suggestion in
the comments and then i will i will
reach your uh suggestion at some point
it's the easiest way to suggest can can
we force
something here is there a force
something
yeah yeah that's nice
that's that's nice that that was the
fourth something we were looking for
all right shirag
not playing currently
maybe more yugoslavian games thanks
thanks mitia batista uh yeah i mean
if a game is good i really i really
don't care who played it i'm like
uh that like really means nothing to me
like i'm from croatia i don't show
games by croatian players but you know
if it's a nice game i will show it
why do i keep showing my usb flash drive
well because it's extremely cool i mean
it's a it's a usb
flash drive that's basically a king and
i i really think it's funny that it's 32
gigabytes
you know and then you have the black
king that's also 32 gigabytes that's 64.
i mean that's
that's pretty awesome habib ishmael
thanks a lot man
yeah that that's a great question kambi
bara why wouldn't i show it i mean
it's a it's a very nice usb flash drive
i've never actually tried using it um
you know just in case it doesn't work i
always wanted to have a
you know a nice uh nice memory
yeah that's the that's king usb yeah
that's king usb
verto yes you can you can join the team
there's a link in the description below
you can just you know click on it
join the team that's it very very
very very simply done
fisher started drinking after he quit
playing chess
i have not heard anything of the sort i
don't think so i don't think he was a
he was a fan of a fan of the the bottle
did magnus lose some focus when he got a
girlfriend i i don't think you can
keep your focus like if it was a 100
and you get a girlfriend i i think it
will at least go down to 99
so yeah i imagine it's
it's impossible to you know keep keep it
uh
at 100 percent
everyone drinks after chess
have i ever covered a game while drunk
you you tell me
will alireza become the next number one
uh it's hard to say how do you how do
you define a number one by being world
champion by being the highest rated by
uh there are many many criteria
like is the world champion really number
one if he's not
highest rated i mean magnus could lose
the
world church championship by a one game
margin and he would still be the highest
rated player in the world
uh it's hard to say like i i think
number one is who the who the general
public
considers number one not nothing else
thank you mandy c thanks for the
contribution
how do i handle chess burnout i don't
think i've ever experienced burnout so
far but
uh i'm not really i'm not really
stressed out
you know with uh with the creating of
content or anything so i don't i don't
fear the burnout per se
alekhine was never number one no i i
don't know
i don't know that's a good question was
a legend ever number one
uh because he
like capablanca never got got around to
you know do a rematch
and uh people it's hard to say i don't
know the
the general opinion like i'm pretty sure
that most considered uh capoblanca
to be the true world champion uh
i will do a lot more research on the
subject when i will be covering the
the whole uh capablanca versus aliakin
clash
but uh yeah it's a very good question
even though alejand was champion was
was he really considered to be the the
number one
after after winning the game against
capoblanca
alright so who do we have next afghan
physicist
yeah i don't think we've seen his game
all right now uh